you're nursing this fantasy that you're
going to go live with your father and
things are going to be all right and
that vanishes the question is why do you
think that translated into the action
you took in the hospital she looked a
lot like my mom I see why did you go
into the hospital do you think we used
to as kids we didn't have any money we
used to go up there and hop the
elevators right up and down oh I see so
that was just something you were in
there doing for fun yeah okay so you
didn't go into the hospital with any
like aggressive intent in
mind and so you saw this woman what
happened
exactly I guess all the
um I
just through the
uh she walks in I was so pissed off that
uh